this is a game that i played in uh 2019
in north carolina actually in
the us masters which is an open
tournament that i played it in august i
tied for first it was it was a fun
tournament and i played a couple of gm's
one of the gm's i played was isan ortiz
suarez from cuba
friend of mine and well not a friend of
mine but we're on good terms and he's a
great guy
and he's also very strong gm you can see
25 51 these are feeder rating i was
playing with the white pieces this is
round seven
i'm having a pretty decent tournament at
this point nothing crazy
and i played a game which i'm really
proud of because it's it's by a larger
positional game but it also features a
lot of sacrifices
so it has the best of both worlds and
uh once again just wanted to give a
shout out to everybody who decides to
sub
and support uh that is always
appreciated it keeps me going and uh
honestly i'm very blessed to have so
many supporters so thank you guys
again uh for for for choosing to support
me
uh it it yeah keeps the engine oiled all
right
so
[Music]
i'm playing white and i actually played
the jabba london
if you guys thought that that i only
played this
in chess.com blitz games you're wrong i
have played this in classical chess many
times
i think it's a really interesting
opening this is called the jaba london
those of you watch my stream
you know that i really like this opening
in blitz but here i played it in
classical we got mr ostrowski
man bonovich with six months thank you
alexander ostrovsky big shout out
um yeah but but this isn't really the
london i mean
it's called the jaba london but it
doesn't have very much in common with
the london
um and i think people need to understand
that there's one very
big distinction uh that needs to be made
between this and the london in the
london you basically have the pawn come
to c3 at some point right
and the point of the london is you keep
this d4 pawn
very well protected that's not really
the point of the jaba
london whatever you want to call it
which is a lot more aggressive
and it's a lot more combative i like the
london i play it myself but
this is you know it's a different
opening entirely
so e6 okay just goes e6
simple move all right good night chess
good knight p5
uh this is actually theory and the point
here is not to
scholars made him on the queen side the
point is that after knight a6 which is
the only good way to defend the pawn
his knight gets misplaced this if you
want to know like gm okay gm chess like
what do gm's do like this is a typical
kind of thing that you would see at a gm
level
which is a move that is aimed at forcing
the opponent into putting a piece on a
bad square
and then potentially just dropping the
knight back to c3
which essentially never ended up
happening until many many moves from now
but it should have and
if he goes bishop d6 instead then i take
the bishop and of course this ruins
black's pawn structure and it gives
white to two bishops which is pretty
good
and so he goes here i go e3 he develops
his bishop i develop my knight
and i go a three why is c6 bad in this
position it blunders into a fork knight
c7 check is a fork
and i take either his rook or or the
queen uh now
okay so bishop b7 knight of three now i
go a3 which is a move i had prepared
before the game
it is an interesting move i think it is
a move that um
i think what is the point of this move
i'm covering the b4 square
so uh if he goes c6 which is what i
anticipated um giusti asks a very
pertinent question wouldn't the opponent
know this line and play against it so
here's the thing
most tournaments in america are two
games a day most tournaments in europe
are one game a day
when there are two games a day the
pairings usually come out 15
20 minutes before the round you have no
time to prepare
also a lot of gm's play a lot of
different openings i play a lot of
different openings i play e4 and d4 even
within those e4 and d4 i play different
openings
it's not easy to predict specifically
the jabal london and even within that
a3 i think is a rare move
so yeah zk that has been played against
me as well i won't delve into that too
much
so the idea of a3 is that after i drop
the knight back he won't have a pesky
pin
such as bishop before he goes then h5
and this
is this is not the mistake the mistake
comes a little bit later
he's going after my bishop and um
he's going after my bishop and it
quickly
dawned on me that i there was no way i
was going to preserve this bishop
in the london you often play the move h3
so that you have that little square on
h2 for the bishop
but one of the things that's important
to realize is that
if you realize that you're going to have
to trade a piece you might as well do
that on your own terms and you might as
well induce
and provoke as many weaknesses as
possible while you're at it
that's what i do here i go bishop e5
okay he chases my bishop with f6 but you
guys see that this also creates
creates a little bit of tenderness on
the king side right it's a little bit
weak right the pawn is weak
you know it's you don't want to play the
move f6 ben fein will never play f6
and now i want you guys to notice
something else
if i take if he takes on g3 i open the h
file
and because i'm uncastled i can now go
bishop d3
and i can combine with the bishop with a
rook rather to attack h7
so he delays taking on g3 he goes c5 and
this is a very big mistake
this is an uncharacteristic mistake from
a grandmaster but it happens
why is this can somebody explain to me
why is the move c5 when you look at it
uh why is it a mistake this opening is
not busted
um it's that's complete malarkey i mean
black equalizes in many different ways
of course
you can never kick the knight away right
and that is huge i mean look at this
because his knight on a6 is paralyzed if
it ever goes to b8 it allows knight c7
so what he should have done is first gun
c6 and
then gone c5 and this would have been
quite a bit better than leaving the
knight on b5 i mean i could go back to
b5
but that's a lot of tempe wasted right
and and i guess he he can trade it off
like this
he goes c5 and uh what i do is i go c4
and i'm like all right bring it on fella
bring it on because he's already created
all these weaknesses
he's left my knight on v5 and now he
wants to open up the center i'm like by
all means
open up the center i want the center to
be open
and i think that this is the move he did
not expect he didn't expect c4
because after this move he settled into
a 30-minute thing he thought forever
and he could not figure out what to do
because if he takes on c4 well guess
what
i bring my bishop out and look at look
at how strong
the bishop is um
and um if he takes the other pawn well
sure i mean i just take back that
doesn't really accomplish anything
um did you give him a bring it on look
after no i'm not a big
um facial expressions guy at the board i
try to be
as sort of low-key as possible
occasionally i'll like look at my
opponent that stuff kind of happens but
not often
um and he finally goes
g6 with the idea that
eventually after i put a bishop on d3
the bishop is going to be blunted
and he's going to be able to take my
bishop on g3 i still go bishop d3 he
takes i take
and he goes knight b8 after another very
long thing
which is an interesting move now the
idea of this move is to get the knight
to c6 on the face of it it looks like a
blunder
isn't he allowing knight c7
well you guys tell me is he not allowing
knight c7
why why is knight c7 not just winning on
the spot and here you just have to look
at the whole board
yeah knight takes g3 he cuts the legs
off and
this is also why he played g6 now if the
pawn were on g7 here
i would probably be able to sacrifice
the knight and go for an attack
in fact there is a beautiful line uh
potentially beautiful lines
where if the pawn was on g7 i'd be able
to sack a bishop
so i can't do that um and i have to
allow him to get his knight to a
civilized square but notice how many
moves he spent doing that
and notice how much he has weakened his
center
in doing that and so i'm able to now put
pressure on his center going rookie one
rookie one um just putting pressure on
the e6 bun he finally takes my bishop he
succumbs
uh and h takes g3 well the thing is
platinum
why was there a lung think after e takes
t surely he'd have calculated that yet
he calculated that very quickly
it's not that he was only he was
considering many different moves
right uh he was considering many
different moves knight b
was only one of the many moves he was
considering and
and he was weighing his options you know
bishop d7 exists he can take my pawn
he can take the bishop so he was
comparing candidate moves
and um he takes and he goes rook f7
trying to kind of build a little bit of
a barrier
and perhaps getting his bishop around to
g7 to protect some of these weakened
king side squares
and now the time has come for white to
formulate a plane i knew that i was
better here i could just sense it
but it took me a while to figure out
what it is that i should do what should
be white's plan here
so i'll let you guys think a little bit
about this
um what do you think i did here what is
white's plan
what do i attack and how do i attack it
and the one hint i will give you is that
flexibility is key you know you ask
what separates gm's from normal players
well flexibility is one of those things
you have to be able to take a piece that
has been perfectly placed for a long
time
and essentially say okay now the piece
has done its job on that square it's
time to re-employ the piece in another
role
so um let's think about it okay
so i see a couple of people noticing the
correct plan very nice you guys are
amazing knight c3
and my plan is very simple i want to
attack this pawn
and you guys might be looking at this
and saying wait attack this one what do
you mean but but can't he just take on
c4 what are you attacking well if he
takes on c4
that's exactly what i want him to do and
akash is on the money
because now look at this pawn on e6 why
do you think i put a rook on e1 because
now his pawn on e6 is essentially
indefensible
so i am attacking the pawn on d5 with
the aim of ultimately winning the pawn
or forcing it to take on c4 and winning
e6
phineas says i don't get it uh
let me know how to rephrase this what
what specifically
uh is mysterious about this and i want
to make sure everybody in the room
elite is the gatekeeper that i am i want
to make sure everybody understands my
explanations
so please give me any questions you have
[Music]
yeah so knight c3 now he goes bishop
f8 and now it's very this is a piece of
advice i have to share
sometimes you come up with a plan and
and and you exit you put your head down
and you sort of execute it but you
always have to watch
for tactics right you cannot just like
blindly
you can't just blindly make moves that
that
are conducive to your plan without
checking them for
random refutations the move queen b3
came to mind it comes to mind
but it's a very bad move because it
allows him to go knight to a5
essentially hitting the queen at a pawn
and and if i move my queen back to a2
then this trade is not good for white i
don't want to get rid of my bishop my
bishop is the
instrument that is attacking e6 now
there's nothing to attack this with
uh so we got is the open a trial a
disadvantage right it's not
right and the analogy that i like to
make in these cases
is to the tree you know if a tree fell
in the forest does anybody hear it
the h file is open but it's not going to
get a rook to h7 anytime soon i mean do
you see that happening anytime soon
i don't that's not gonna happen in
theory
i would perhaps like my pawn to be on h2
but it's really not going to affect me
so i go before and uh we had machaco's i
think called it
because not only am i expanding on the
queen side but i'm covering the a5
square i'm creating kind of a shell
be behind which i'm going to put my
queen he goes 97
lending reinforcement to d5 and i go
queen b3
and he goes king to g7 he's basically
getting his king out of
out of the diagonal there's not not very
much that black can do here
so again i asked myself well what do i
do
do i continue to pressure the d5 fund or
do i come up with a different plan
and i i came up with the idea of
doubling on the e file and just putting
more pressure in general on his center
uh which which is not a you know crazy
idea it's just i want to improve all my
pieces
he goes bishop d7 i double and he goes
rook c8
and this is one of basically three
super important moments in the game this
is where i feel like i did something
really really strong and
this is why i'm really proud of this
game okay
this is why i'm really proud of this
game because i mentioned before the
concept of flexibility right
you you're doing something for five six
moves and all of a sudden
you switch plans entirely you realize
that the position demands something else
and i did that here
so what is the most tempting thing to do
the question is what to do with the cpan
right cd
wins upon and it seems like why i've
succeeded yes i've won his pawn and
everything i've been doing up to this
point in my entire life
is is culminates in this moment when
i've won upon
but i looked one step further and i
realized he goes bishop c6
and i looked at this position for a
second and i said damn this doesn't look
like what i thought it would i mean
there's no champagne bottles opening
because i have a weak pawn he's got a
blockading square on d5
and the queen trade is this doesn't lead
to an endgame that seemed particularly
easy to win
i mean i i i can go bishop before
uh and um you know i can trade bishops
but
i didn't feel like my bond would be
going anywhere so i really didn't like
this i rejected it
and i thought i can do better than that
if this is
all that i've been leading up to this
entire time
then that's a crying shame so i started
thinking about what
what else i could try to do here uh
and i came up with a really really
strong idea
so the idea that i came up with and i'll
tell you guys the first move just
because it seems very counter-intuitive
the first move is c5
what the hell are you doing right you're
actually letting this pawn off the hook
um you know isn't that counterproductive
to everything you've been doing he goes
g5 he starts expanding on the king side
and this is where i played the follow-up
move to c5 i'd like you guys to take a
stab at it
what did i do in this position with
white
because and this is you know
it's a move that i'm going to have a
hard time explaining entirely but i'll
try my best
yes rook takes c6 very nice
now this is what's known as a positional
sacrifice
i am sacrificing the exchange for a pawn
so it's not like a huge sacrifice
what is it that i'm getting in return
well what the question
as ferry spieler would say is not what
i'm getting in return it's what i what
i'm not getting in return
first of all look at this d-pod this
d-pawn is now isolated and it's on a
light square
which means it can be potentially
attacked by the bishop
if this one falls i'm going to have a
huge pawn phalanx that's going to go
forth
and destroy everything in its path and
we will see that in the game
in addition his entire position is just
he's paralyzed
there's just nothing he can move he
can't move a muscle
uh and you know he can't move his knife
because the pawn is saying his king side
is terribly weak
i also have the possibility of building
a battery with bishop b1 queen c2
and targeting that pawn so there's just
so many considerations here that are
going for white i didn't even really
calculate this i just went for it
intuitively
so ortiz goes a6 he he covers the b5
square
and now i go bishop b1 i felt like this
was the most flexible move because
there's two ideas one is to go bishop a2
and build a battery against the d-pawn
the other is to go queen c2
build a battery against the king but my
opponent goes rook c6 and i started
doubting myself a little bit because
first thing i thought was well i
certainly don't want to take on c6 i
mean that that's
terrible because he takes with the pawn
and he cements
the d-pawn that's counterproductive to
what i'm trying to do
my next thought was okay let me just get
the rook back but there's something
about this move that just didn't sit
right with me
white is much better here but i didn't
want to move the rook back
i wanted to find something that carried
a little bit more punch
and this is where i came up with and i
don't say this
lightly about my ideas i haven't come up
with a lot of these ideas but i believe
i came up with a brilliant idea
and you guys are spotting it immediately
i am thoroughly impressed
rook takes c7 i sack another exchange
two positional exchange sacrifices in
one game
and i played this move right in the
presence of another gm that was
observing my game i was like i'm either
crazy
or this is going to be a brilliancy and
this is the top computer move
rook takes c7 is the top computer move
and that is what filled me with joy
after the game i actually did this
correctly if you see
stockfish 12 rookie 7 is plus 5
and i can show you guys uh i can just
quickly move my webcam out of the way
well no you you know yeah just trust me
i'm running it right now
that is the top move
now how did what why is this so strong
there's again three main reasons to
delineate here
and one second so
okay why is this cut off a little bit
okay
now after bishop queen takes c7 knight
takes d5
what you'll see is three things to point
the first
is look at this diagonal black no longer
has a light squared bishop which means
if white puts a queen on c2
this is going to be absolutely
devastating along this diagonal
the other is this knight on d5 where can
it maneuver itself to
it can come around as joe dorban is
pointing out from e3 to f5
and remember i mentioned this pawn mass
that pawn on d5 well nobody canceled
that idea
the pawn from d4 can run to d6 and just
smash everything in its path
so the the positional domination over
black's pieces
regardless of the fact that he's got two
rooks which don't matter i don't give a
damn about that
my knights are much stronger my pieces
are my stronger because of the abundance
of positional advantages i have at my
disposal
he goes queen e6 now the only thing i
had to see when i
sacked was this position because he pins
my knight to my queen and i would love
to play knight e3 but i can't so i
only calculated the next two moves and
the move that i spotted here was queen
d3
this is the move i had to see because if
queen takes d5 then i take with
checkmate
he has to attend to that he goes kch8
now i bring my knight back to e3 and
this is where i stopped calculating
because i realized that i have the
threat of d5 i have the threat of knight
f5
black is just totally tied hand and foot
and
my the position just plays itself he
goes rook back to c8 i go d5 and d6 i
mean just driving the pawn end
my next couple of moves are probably
going to be just knight f5 g4 and bishop
a2
so isan my opponent tries to change the
nature of the position he takes on d6
out of total desperation he tries to
sack a bunch of stuff
and now he sacks another exchange back
and he gets rid of my puns
but now i have two beautiful knights
against the rook and his king is still
very weak and i still
have access to this dominant square on
f5
there is a question by um amitabh
atrei why can't black play f5 that's a
great question
he can but i'll still go knight e3 and
in addition to this threat i now have
this threat in this threat so
there's just too much hanging here he
goes bishop roxy one takes knight f5
queen d3 just bringing the queen back
into the game the rest is
is not that interesting i just basically
put all my knights
all over the place i mean look at this
knight comes to h6 to f5
now the move queen f3 basically ends the
game because
i am creating a fork against these two
pawns and it's not even about pawns here
it's about the fact that his king is
just
in total ruins and he resigned in this
position time control has been made
why did he resign because if he moves
his rook out of the way i go knight f7
knight h6 uh and then i basically win
his queen there's a that's one of a
million different
possible wins here the white is not even
in a hurry so that's
that's the game so what was black's
mistake so as i explained i think c5 was
a huge mistake
i also think that he should probably
have taken on c4 sooner i'm not sure
when
maybe he should have done this and then
this i don't know
and tried to give up a pawn and and play
for the d5 square
once he allowed c5 i think he's already
almost losing
and once he and g5 was definitely a
mistake as well because he did not
expect this exchange sacrifice
what he did was he set me up for this
because he opened up this diagonal
he should have just hunkered down and uh
this other exchange sacrifice i mean it
was not my best game ever but i think it
might have been my best positional
effort
in a very long time um and it shows you
a couple of things it shows you that
you can play these offbeat openings over
the board i appreciate it akash and
thank you for the five subs uh
the gratitude is all owed to you guys
you are who support me and
uh this is just fun for me uh so i'm
very happy that people are enjoying and
benefiting truly
[Music]
you